Now, let's discuss a special kind of
memory resident virus called Rootkit.
A Rootkit is embedded
in an operating system.
It typically modifies some of
the code and even data structures
of the operating system in order to
perform some malicious activities.
For example, a Rootkit can be used
to hide a malware from he user.
For example, when the user uses the
hours command to list the contents of
a directory, the Rootkit can change
the output of the LS command so
that the user will not
see the malware file.
Similarly, when the user
uses the PS command
to see what programs are running
on a system, the Rootkit
can modify the output of the PS command
to hide the running of the malware.
Let's study an example of how Rootkit
can modify the operating system
in order to perform
malicious activities.
For example, the rootkit is trying to
hide the malware file from the user
when he lists the contents
of a directory.
First, let's examine what happens when a
user looks at the files in a directory.
Suppose on Windows,
the user use the command D-I-R, DIR,
for looking at files in a directory.
As we show here this command
can be implemented by a loop
that keeps looking at the next
file in the directory.
Now, let's look at how
a Rootkit can hide a malware
from the user when he looks
at the files in a directory.
We know that files and directories,
they reside on hard drive, which is
controlled by the operating system.
Meaning that,
any access to the hard drive has to
go through the operating system.
Therefore, in order to get informations
about files in the directory we have to
go through operating system functions
in order to get such information.
In other words, operating system
functions are being called
to look at informations about files and
directories on hard drive and
return the results back to the user.
So here is what an operating
system will typically return
when the user looks at
the files in a directory.
That is, suppose the Rootkit is
not embedded in the OS yet, then
the OS will return all the files in the
directory including the malware file,
say mal_code.exe.
And this is the file that the Rootkit
would try to hide from the user.
In order to hide the malware from
the user, what the Rootkit can do
is to intercept any function
call to the operating system.
And then reason whether the call
will end up revealing the malware.
And if no,
it will just pass the call to the
appropriate operating system function.
And if yes, it's going to execute
the call, but intercept the result so
that it can filter out the result as
necessary, in order to hide the malware.
That is the Rootkit intercepts
the function call to
the operating system and
knows that the operating system function
call is looking at files in a directory,
and then it knows that the return
results may contain the malcode.exe.
So the Rootkit will filter
out the file name so
that the user will not see
this file name in the result.
So here you go, when the Rootkit is
embedded in the operating system,
you can filter out the malware file.
So when a user looks at
the files in a directory,
he will not be able to
see the malware and
this is how a root kit in the OS
can hide a malware from the user.
Again, the root kit is able to
accomplish this by modifying
the operating system.
In particular, it intercepts a function
called to the operating system, and
future the result of the function calls.